yo J ski is the separation of Jordan Miz
and Jordan highs drumwork music was good
make sure you check me out on the
bootleg cab podcast tap in let's go
everything for wheeze
bootleg cat podcast we got a special
guest in here his debut album
something like a debut album it's out
right now abolished uncertainties yes
sir yes sir now you've been putting out
like like you know bodies of work so
what makes this like the uh official I
guess like debut man it's something I've
been working on for a long time
um you know I've been working on it
since like the end of 2020.
um you know what I mean it has like it's
my whole life you know what I mean when
I think about abolishing certainties
it's just my story you know what I mean
I say it on the first record it's like
I'm telling my story you know what I'm
saying so I feel like with the other uh
with some of the other projects that I
have you know I was more so because it
was like you know you got Revolver
Ocelot you got Iroquois gonna join out
there with big gold so authenticity
check that's me more soldiers trying to
show people that I belong here in the
game and like I can spit you know what I
mean and with this joint it's like you
get a full like you get a full kind of
uh feel for my Artistry like when it
comes to not only just rhyming because
you know rhyming is the easy part
putting together like real songs and
putting together something that someone
can really digest and really get a feel
of who this artist is there it is man
um first of all for people who don't
know you originally
before you linked with drum work in
Conway you were kind of working you were
like the sneaker guy so you were working
out of a sneaker store in Buffalo yeah
yeah so were you kind of like ever known
to be a rapper at that same time or are
you kind of like everyone's sneaker plug
like kind of breaking up no I was uh you
know I was working like you know I was
the manager at the sneaker spot for a
long time so you were the plug yeah kind
of not really not really because I
wasn't on no back door [__] you couldn't
set some shoes aside for someone I could
if you if I really [__] with you yeah
you know what I'm saying but outside of
that I wasn't really doing that type of
[__] I was just really working there to
try and support my dream right you know
what I mean and uh you know people
definitely knew that I was you know I
was rapping back then too because I was
doing like ciphers and uh they're at the
store actually I was doing that I was
doing shows all around the town I was
doing shows out of town so you know it
was just something that I was doing in
the time so that I could you know just
support the dream and just support
myself so what ended up kind of being
um the bridge from you doing that to
sign in with uh drum work it was really
like the pandemic like once the pandemic
came around I got very low from work
because you know nobody was going to the
sneaker store to go buy no kicks and
[__] so right you know uh we ended up
you know all getting furloughed there at
the store and um you know I was just
locking in and you know when the
opportunity came back to go back to the
store and work
um the company I was working for they
just what company was it um if you ever
heard of DTLR Villa oh yeah DTLR yeah I
was working with DTLR and they they just
you know it was just a few situations
that happened there in the store
um where I just wasn't comfortable
working in the store and I ended up
leaving and uh you know two days later
that's when Conway reached out to me you
know what I mean like I kind of just
took a big leap of faith and just
trusted God and you know I didn't know
where I was going to go next or what was
going to happen next but you know it
just didn't feel right I wasn't I felt
like I wasn't being treated like a human
being at the end of the day that I had
value well I feel like too the last
couple years you've kind of gone through
like some real like artist development
like I feel like you've been putting out
music but you've also been kind of able
to sit to the side and watch you know go
to these big Griselda shows or go do
South like last year you did South by
Southwest um I think
I don't I forget why Conway couldn't
make it but I remember there was a show
that last year I saw you do with a stove
God but like it was dope to see like
kind of like I feel like every time I
see you you're kind of like getting the
like standing on your own a little bit
more because I feel like it's hard to
come in when you're coming in with
somebody like Conway because everyone's
going to kind of associate you guys
together
um but I feel like you've done a good
job of kind of being your own man you
know what I mean that's that's like one
of the biggest things for me is is crazy
that you even bring that up because
everything that I've done to this point
has been to support that right you know
what I mean because like you said it is
kind of hard like you know it's hard to
have two stars really shine bright
together but I know like you know I know
I'm a star too so you know I got to do a
good job of making that known and just
you know anytime that I do have a chance
to kind of you know do a show separate
like separately or you know just do my
own thing you know I mean I always take
those opportunities like Conway that's
my big brother you know what I'm saying
like shout out to the big bro you know
what I'm saying but you know I gotta
shine too you know what I'm saying and
that's what I'm gonna do Yeah March big
month for you man yeah for sure you guys
uh got the uh the The Joint project
which dropped on the 10th he got the
album was it was this kind of like the
conscious decision to be like yo it's
your time right now like yeah put up the
runway put out the runway man um and you
know shout out to Chad and everybody
over at drum work Conway for kind of
putting that together my man Dave over
at Empire you know what I'm saying like
it was it was like a conscious decision
to say yo let's just put out this
project you know we have been sitting on
it for a little bit pain provided profit
let's put it out and then you know why
not just drop the drop the album two
weeks later because it's like you know
you already have the floor you know what
I mean 100 was there ever
um wasn't there supposed to be a
drumwork compilation
yeah yeah and it still is um that'll be
coming I believe
um if if not April it'll be May so
that's on the way yeah it's on the way
so much drum work happening yeah man yes
it's time because you know we've been
we've been grinding for like the last
two and a half years for sure so it's
like you know now is like the perfect
time because people been waiting on it
you know what I mean like we all been
putting out our own little projects and
videos and different things making sure
that our presence is known but now it's
like nah let's do the drumwork thing for
sure uh abolish uncertainties why the
title so when I was thinking about
naming the album it was it came at a
time where I wasn't sure
um what was where I was going really in
life like I said like you know I just
quit my job and so you named this a
while ago yeah I named this a while ago
yeah this was uh back in 2020 I was
thinking of a name and so um you know I
was I was just always unsure man being
from Buffalo you know it wasn't a lot of
opportunities for people to get on with
music especially hip-hop you know what
I'm saying so you know when uh Griselda
you know they kicked on the door it was
kind of like well [__] maybe I do got a
shot at this for real and then you still
got uncertainties though because you
know it how am I gonna do it I that I
wasn't sure of you know what I mean so
you know with this album I feel like I'm
really
um I'm taking whatever whatever like
chains and whatever uh it's almost like
cuffs that you have on your mind because
you can you can kind of enslave yourself
you know I mean you'd be a slave to your
mind because you start thinking so much
and then you got all these thoughts and
they just go and go and go and kind of
Psych yourself out yeah exactly so you
know I'm abolishing I was thinking about
it I was like yo I'm gonna abolish these
chains that I had on my mind
are the mental yeah all that yeah it's
like abolishing slavery I should say but
yeah like take those chains off of my
mind because with this album this is
like my first real statement and you
know in the game you know what I'm
saying like that's how it really feels
who's on the album oh [__] I got Conway
on there I got uh I got freeway on there
shout out my bro freeway man he came
through
um I got uh Jillian Haynesworth she's a
poet from the town okay I got my man
Terry King on there shout out my man
Terry King he's an awesome comedian and
I got Cody Sevilla she's an awesome
artist she she sings she raps she does
it all so when you hit freeway for the
future is it pretty like just you got to
pay for it I'll tell you how how I even
got that feature so uh Beanie Siegel and
freeway they both came through Buffalo
and they had a show and I was at the
studio that night and um Conway was
supposed to pull up and come to the
studio and they were gonna pull up so
they pulled up uh I'm sorry uh beanie
and free they pulled up and um we was
just sitting in the studio just vibing
and so I met DJ Coles he he was like yo
start playing your album yeah and so you
know beanie and uh free they came in the
stool and Kai never he never came
through it sounds about right
uh bro came you know what I'm saying
they came in the studio
and uh you know I'm playing all my all
my records from abolish uncertainties
that I had so far and uh I got this
record on there it's called out here
that came on and the flow that I use on
there is just crazy
it's almost kind of like some freeways
right you know what I'm saying uh he's a
big inspiration to me for sure and so uh
you know the record comes on and I just
see him so he's sitting in the corner
I'm sitting in like the middle of like
the studio he's sitting in the corner
and I'm watching him like his whole
reaction is just like yo this showing
this crazy like you know what I'm saying
going back and forth and um you know the
song goes off and I'm like yo bro like
it's room for you on there he's like
well I'm like yo there's room for you on
that record like I see you over there
vibing like you know hop on it man you
know what I'm saying like he was like yo
run it back so we played it back he was
like yo let's do it so immediately like
I'm like yo my man Tony boy will say I'm
like yo Tony boy load up the session
let's get it he did his verse right
there on the spot it was love
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
Odd Socks baby that's right shout out to
Odd Socks little Godfather sock right
there craziest licenses in the game the
most comfortable socks period And if you
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws let's pop these boys open
check them out oh yeah oh yeah a little
Chun Lee versus Blanco
what
amazing
do you like YooHoo so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet I promise
you you gotta go to autotoxofficial.com
right now and use the promo code bootleg
save 20 off your entire order all right
so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview
I was talking to Conway on camera about
his relationship with Beanie Siegel and
he insinuated that there might be
something coming down the pipeline with
Beanie Siegel I wish I knew but that
lock load is a crazy record yeah that
was like that was like a year and a half
ago yeah yeah lock load is crazy oh my
god
um hey uh so you're a big sneaker guy
yeah give me your top five like sneakers
silhouettes of all time Silhouettes not
even like specifically yeah so I'm gonna
go uh Jordan eights Jordan Fives Jordan
Ones for sure you know I'm the
separation of Jordan Miz and Jordan
highs I've been going by that for the
longest
um Air Force ones of course and for that
last spot
kind of tough
but I'ma say
I really love the Air Raids okay I
really love the air right so you're
gonna put the Jordan eights number one
Jordan yeah Aquas bro oh man aqua's
black and chrome eights [__] hate
what are we talking about bro that's the
hardest shoe ever bro nah give me the
cement threes symmetries is tough too
you know what I'm saying
but you know so you're like an eight
you're like eight yeah like eights
that's my shoe you're like a unicorn
yeah for real that's that's my shoe I
feel like my shoes I feel like I don't I
don't own a pair of eights I don't even
the aqua eights I'm just I'm straight
they're just like the straps and so you
gotta it's just a certain way you gotta
wear them you get drippy in them joints
though I'm sure you can yeah for sure I
don't think I'm interested in getting
drippings of jordanates hey man teachers
on man and the sixes I feel like six is
sit you said there's I feel like anytime
sixes drop recently they're sitting
everywhere yeah you know I feel that way
too I think they just dropped like some
more gray ones the wolf gray ones are
everywhere yeah they're everywhere for a
fact they gotta bring back some of those
classic colors man those Jordan fours
those SBS are about to drop Crazy Fire
crazy I'm hoping I can get my hands on
them but I'll never have no luck on Nike
app so the Nike app is trash yeah are
those on the Nike app because they're SB
I don't know if they're I think they
might drop on the Nike app yeah there
was a store that we used to go to man
back in the day um it was over on
Elmwood and buffalo and uh it was called
Sunday I believe Sunday skate shop and
they would get like those collabs like I
got a pair of ones from there back in
the day man it's it's tough to get your
hands on the SB collides when they do
them if someone goes to Buffalo where do
they get buffalo wings from Buffalo
wings from you gotta go to um I love
Kelly Corner Wings I've been there yeah
Kelly Corner that place is interesting
yeah it's different and it got a
different type of like hot wing too
because it's not like a sauce yeah it
was just some old lady there smoking and
serving drinks yeah with the glasses she
was just a one-person staff yeah she's
been in there thugging for a long time
because [__] the first time I went there
was maybe five six years ago I was like
I hope she sweats in our wings because I
feel like that would be the special
ingredient for real from Kelly's corner
for real so go to Kelly's corner
get you a Guinness it's definitely like
a bar yeah yeah it's a bar yeah
um uh listen for you like talk about
for like your if you know if you've been
planning this album for two years you
came up with the title during the
pandemic
do you feel any pressure are you nervous
at all like how people are going to
receive receive something that you've
put so much into no I'm not nervous at
all because you know I put my I put my
life into it right you know what I mean
it's authentic it's it's like it's one
of those projects where when you walk
away from it like I said you just get a
real sense of who the artist is and
every song like me as an artist period
I've never I've never wanted to be put
into a box and so there's a lot of
different flows a lot of different
sounds on there different beats and so
it's it's got something for everybody
you know what I mean like when I say
I'll be joking with my man child all the
time and I say yo we go on Billboard
number one and I always like I'm I'm
serious because you know what I mean I
feel like the project just speaks to
everybody it's a song on the album that
everyone can like but as a as a whole
like as a body of work it's just a
beautiful like piece of work like I
can't really say too much else about it
and it's me you know what I mean so if
you [__] with Jay skis you know what I
mean like you'll appreciate it you'll
love it and if not if you don't even
know who Jay skis is it's a song on
there that's gonna reel you in you know
what I'm saying for for the like when I
always wondered this when these like big
ghost albums happen have you met big
ghost does anybody know who this guy is
Yo the crazy [__] about big ghosts is
one day randomly right I think this was
after uh cracking the 90s came out right
he randomly followed me and so I knew
about Big ghosts from like 2009 he was
like on Twitter yeah no not even on
Twitter I used to read his um his blog
spot or whatever or whatever it was yeah
I remember he had like it was a vlog
spot I used to read that joint and so
I'm because he had the one joint about
Drake and a few other reviews right from
like the perspective of Ghostface or
whatever and that [__] was just mad
funny I'm like yo this [__] is crazy so
when I saw his name follow me I
instantly followed back and then I DM
them like yo bro much respect man I've
been [__] with you for a long time
and he hit me back like yo now I [__]
with you too so that whole tape like
came through Instagram DM I've never met
that man
so he does not actually have anything to
do with the music does he no he does he
does he has a lot to do so is he sending
you beats is he making the Beats so he
makes Beats well I think he I think he I
think he has a team that he works with
to to and they've probably never met him
either yeah probably not
or everybody's just keeping it a secret
but shout out to him man yeah shout out
to Big ghost man run it up man big homie
uh you're obviously a huge video game
guy what do you what games are you
playing lately yo to be honest I haven't
had no time to play no video games bro
you're not playing Hogwarts I'm not
playing [__] no I've been yo I've been
I've been so so focused on this music
bro and just moving around and doing
what I got to do like the most I might
play is like maybe Mario ultimate Mario
or whatever on my on my Nintendo switch
on the switch you move around with the
switch Yeah I do I do I keep the switch
on me you got to keep the switch on you
as long as it's the Nintendo kind yeah
exactly uh what about all time what are
your favorite games give me your top
five [__] Metal Gear Solid for sure
what's the best metal gear solid to you
to me it's Metal Gear Solid 3 the Sons
of Liberty you know what I'm saying I
love that joint I thought it was dope
like once once you get you know what I'm
saying the first person mode I thought
that [__] was just mad ill and in the
story period for Metal Gear Solid it's
just dope as hell yeah no part one's my
favorite game ever yeah so I like I like
part one too
um but yeah Metal Gear Solid for sure
um Final Fantasy VII that's a great game
raw as hell triple disc yep yeah [__]
was crazy was it three or two discs it
was it was two it was just two not three
yeah it was two
um GoldenEye 007 yeah that was one of my
favorites for sure didn't age well the
names well you don't think so I just
played it recently I just played it
recently too that [__] was raw yeah you
know what I played it on a mod so I
didn't have the actual like yeah see you
gotta you gotta really had a controller
all that bro that's good so maybe that
was why yeah that's gonna take you um
Matt it was it's a specific matter no I
think it was Madden 08
I want to say it was like Sean Alexander
or somebody but that [__] was raw that
was like the illest one it was the one
where you had like The Mulligans and
[__] I always just felt like the
gameplay I [__] with NFL 2K I figured
which 2K was yeah one of the Randy
Marshall now the 2K joints was fire
it was Vince Young okay one of the one
of the two k's were dope yeah I was
gonna say it was the one with Randy Moss
but I think they all had Randy Moss yeah
2K both 2ks it was like NFL had Randy
every year and then AI was on the cover
of the first like three copy NBA ones um
last one though is uh Resident Evil 2
for the PlayStation classic classic love
Resident Evil too thanks for sure man
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about the homies at my
bookie bet on anything anywhere anytime
at mybookie.ag and check this out if you
sign up right now with the keyword
bootleg you're gonna get a first deposit
bonus up to a thousand dollars and
that's not it
if you sign up with that keyword bootleg
not only will you get that first deposit
bonus up two thousand dollars but you're
also gonna get a free 50 000 sweet 16
bracket entry so many ways to win at
mybookie.ag I've been using them for
about 10 years now trust me when I say
I'm not co-signing them because they're
dropping the bag I mean that's nice but
I've been literally using my bookie for
the better part of the last decade to
put all my sports bets in to play a
little online roulette a little
Blackjack a little craps it's all there
they got the live casino they got so
much going on look March Madness is
where it's at right now you can get down
with that uh sweet 16 the elite eight
the NCAA Final Four all of it NBA season
in full effect baseball is about to kick
off get in on the action bet on anything
anytime anywhere right now with my
bookie so sign up at mybookie.ag use
that promo code bootleg right now for
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and a free 50 000 sweet
16 bracket entry hey also shout out to
the homies at Bluetooth man don't forget
if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction in if your penis is not
functioning correctly it's a little
flaccid you're trying to get it a little
hard a lot of hard rather Bluetooth is
where it's at a lot of people ask me you
always talking about Bluetooth does it
work yes it works all right uh listen it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and a Cialis but it's in a chewable form
all right it is sent right to your door
uh in a discrete package it's a great
thing man go to bluetooth.com right now
you use that promo code bootleg right
now you're gonna get a month supply for
free of Bluetooth why not have some
better sex okay seriously uh there's so
many other ways you can get down too
because they just dropped the Bluetooth
mint flavor which is the same active
ingredient as Levitra just so many
things we can do here uh and look when
you go to bluetooth.com and you sign up
with that promo code bootleg they're
gonna literally send it straight to your
crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a Bluetooth use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free all right so the album is well by
the time this comes out the album will
be out yeah what is your favorite song
on the album
that's a great question bro I think my
favorite song on the album
and that's a crazy question I think it's
got to be I got a song on there called
red Kool-Aid okay and that's the one I
was I was talking about Julian
Haynesworth she's on there oh I got
origino on the album too I don't even
know how I missed that he's a he's a
singer from the town as well he's an
artist he's a great Artist as well
um but red Kool-Aid I talk about three
different stories uh very short verses
and um
you know I'm just describing different
things that have happened in my life and
why I am the way that I am and then
Jillian gets on there and she does this
poem for about a minute and a half man
and it's like some of the things she
says in the poem it's just like every
time I listen to it it gives me chills
you know what I mean so it's a it's a
just an amazing song Man in this
production
um by Buddha and Grands it's just it's
just an amazing song period so the
album's out you got the album Conway out
drum work project coming soon
any uh how's the Conway album sound in
that we've all been waiting for I mean
Conway bro you know what I mean you know
like you don't exactly know what you get
with Conway but you know what you're
getting with Conway bro like he had told
me that he was waiting for a really big
feature yeah I don't know if it happened
I haven't heard anything about it yet
because I'm not sure who it is but Jay-Z
Jay-Z that's what he told me I was like
yo what the [__] when is that bro you
know I'm waiting for that whole feature
yeah I mean [__] I hope it happens man
you know what I'm saying like Jay is Jay
is the goat so you know what I mean but
nah the Conway album so far man is
it's Fire Man like are you on it [__]
hell yeah I'm on there yeah we got a
song on there it's it's crazy
um I I don't want to give away too much
about it I probably hurt my project but
I think I've heard the whole album oh
where except for I think there's one or
two songs Chad said I haven't heard yet
yeah no the album album is crazy for
sure man album is crazy
um people buy merch you're gonna do the
vinyl drop you can do all that
um I don't know because I think that's
gonna be through the label
um but I'm pretty sure you know it'll be
something like that well you can do
you're gonna do merch to the label I
believe so through Empire all right well
listen yeah so we'll see what happens
Jay skis appreciate you pulling up go
get the album and he just killed this
crazy [__] freestyle it was insane
different YouTube video but yeah go
watch that no doubt no doubt boom
appreciate you brother you all ready yes
sir